et ses accusations sur la présence de
militaires russes au mali lancé à la
fois par la france et bamako on sait
l'objet de notre décryptage avec régis
le sommier qui est resté avec nous et
xavier moreau directeur strates paul
bonsoir xavier moreau merci d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui donc moscou qui prend
la parole en et dément formellement la
présence de ses troupes une une réponse
d'eads et moraux à à la france qui
verrait cette initiative d'un très
mauvais oeil
si vous voulez le les mercenaires ça
sert à ça sert à pouvoir intervenir dans
des zones particulières sans engager un
état et surtout sans engager sa
diplomatie donc aujourd'hui moi je n'ai
pas d'information particulière
permettrait de confirmer ou d'infirmer
qu'il y a des des mercenaires russes sur
place mais je dirais que c'est de bonne
guerre le sait le deuxième plus vieux
métier du monde et ça a été largement
utilisé par la russie notamment en syrie
où quand vous voulez envoyer les gens
faire des guerres on vous ne voulez pas
être impliqué directement ou que vous ne
voulez pas que les mères de famille des
conscrits russes ou même des
professionnels russes et bien pleure la
mort de leurs soldats lorsque vous
envoyez des mercenaires c'est ce que les
russes ont fait en centrafrique c'est là
la france le fait les états unis le
fonds est généralement ça apparaît après
des conflits où il ya énormément de
volontaires et c'était le cas notamment
du conflit en ukraine vous avez
énormément de groupes qui sont allés
volontaire dans de bonnes basses et qui
ont pris goût et bien à cette manière de
vivre et notamment de gagner et de
gagner sa vie et c'est pas hasard si
d'ailleurs wagner est réellement apparu
après les événements en ukraine alors le
ministre malien de la défense eut admis
emmener ses pourparlers avec cette
société militaire privée levin se
souvient quel est l'intérêt de mieux
pouvoir malien de changer finalement
d'interlocuteurs dans sa lutte contre
les groupes jihadistes alors c'est pas
complètement changer d'interlocuteur en
tout cas
on sait que les relations sont
difficiles entre emmanuel macron et
assimilés aux états qui est le double
putschistes puisqu'il a donc renouvelé
son coup d'état l'année dernière on sait
que
il ya eu plus il ya eu des tensions
emmanuel macron ont décidé de mettre fin
à l'opération barkan pour
progressivement la transformer entre une
opération impliquant les forces
spéciales européennes sous la forme de
ce qu'on appelle la taskforce takouba et
que voilà le le deal qui est en train
d'être fait enfin la la la la le point
d'achoppement le point de discussion
entre les français et les maliens
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir si les
maliens vont s'entendre en tout cas vont
essayer de faire revenir dans l'équation
nationale d un certain nombre de groupes
djihadistes deux groupes ce qu'on
appelle les gâte là bas les groupes
armés terroristes avec lesquels il ya
des discussions tout simplement le
colonel bou et a été lui même capturé
par un de ces groupes et il a été libéré
par un imam célèbre là bas qui s'appelle
l'imam dicko qui lui négocié beaucoup
avec ces groupes et donc à une tente est
entation une tentative justement de la
part du gouvernement de d'essayer de
devoir mais jusqu'où va certes cette
tentative et c'est là où la présence
française là bas est mise en cause c'est
à dire que les françaises là qu'est ce
qu'ils font ils font la chasse à ces
groupes armés terroristes ils essayent
de rétablir une forme de légitimité du
pouvoir dans le pays et en même temps le
gouvernement malien lui négocié avec ses
routes d'aucun il ya un conflit qui ce
prêt qui se entre les deux et est le
problème qui est posé aujourd'hui je
pense que c'est la finalité de
l'intervention française qu'une
intervention qui date depuis 2013 je le
rappelle d'abord c'est l'intervalle et
ensuite en 2014 marc khanne aujourd'hui
la l'école la force est en train de
muter elle est mais elle est toujours
très investi 1 moi j étais j'étais sur
ta coups de bras j'étais j'ai participé
des opérations avec eux cette tâche
force en avril dernier je voudrais dans
la zone de ménaka quitte à l'est du pays
qui était une zone une petite commune
petite garnison il ya deux ans
aujourd'hui une base gigantesque est en
train de se construire avec une présence
des tchèques une présence des suédois
une présence des commandes et estoniens
toutes les beaucoup de pays sont sont là
pour effectivement
continuer cette traque aux terroristes
dans le sahel le problème c'est qu'à en
parallèle il ya eu peu de résultats dans
la reconstitution d'un service public
dans certaines zones et que les
terroristes finalement sont comme des
poissons dans l'eau donc c'est un
conflit qui semble être un conflit sans
fin avec ce qui s'est passé en
afghanistan est revenue dans l'est que
la question à nouveau été posée c'est de
se dire
la france et l aile ou six engagés dans
un conflit sans fin la france est elle
doit elle rester indéfiniment au sahel
au risque de voir le pays s'écroule et
c'est ce qu'on avait dit à propos des
états unis pour l'afghanistan c'est ce
qu'on la dit également pour l'irak donc
le la question elle est là aujourd'hui
maintenant d'autres partenaires d'autres
comme aux acteurs existent dans l'ain
dans les environs les maliens joue sur
plusieurs tableaux ça c'est évident
maintenant la réalité tangible de
l'accord avec le groupe wagner on n'en
sait rien on n'en sait rien on a quand
même le précédent qui avait été cité
tout à l'heure de la centrafrique où le
groupe wagner a formé la garde nationale
du président a formé une partie de
l'armée donc a déjà pris souche dans un
pays qui était autrefois un territoire
français enfin un territoire de soude
influence française et xavier moreau en
tout cas la france elle ne veut pas en
entendre parler jean yves le drian était
bien clair il a prévenu que
l'implication de ce groupe serait
absolument incompatible avec le maintien
de la force française ça pourrait
peut-être dans le contexte vient nous
expliquer régis le sommier s'avérer fort
utile la france est en mauvaise posture
est quasi sûr la fin au mali
je dois je suis d'accord avec ce que
vient diriger ce sommet c'est à dire que
pour les deux dirigeants maliens c'est
un bon moyen de faire pression sur la
france puisqu'il ya le précédent
centrafricain et c'est pas parce que
wagner est impliqué que l'armée russe va
immédiatement débarquer donc là-dessus
qu'il faut être il faut être modéré je
pense qu'aujourd'hui les russes n'ont
pas l'ambition de remplacer dans une
zone qui est kama s'éloigner de leurs
centres d'intérêt de remplacer l'armée
française où la coalition européenne en
question vraiment je sais que ça c'est
vrai que les
les affres et les dirigeants africains
sont pas sont pas plus idiot que les
autres et ils ont bien compris que il
était désormais courtisé pour
différentes raisons politico
stratégiques comme le leur foi par
exemple au sein de l'assemblée des
nations unies il était concilie était
courtisé par la chine par la russie la
russie a tenu son sommeil russe afrique
en novembre 2019 toutes les grandes
puissances africaines étaient présentes
et pour le les autorités maliennes
actuelle c'est un très bon moyen de
faire pression sur la france pour les
obliger d'une part peut-être un service
tirant davantage et surtout pour ne pas
vouloir s'immiscer dans les affaires
intérieures de ce qu'ils estiment être
les affaires intérieures des autorités
maliennes parce que ça aussi c'est une
spécificité de la diplomatie russe et
qu'elle ne fait pas de leçons de morale
aux dents dans les pays dans lequel dans
lequel elle s'investit allait prendre
toujours du recul contient un coup
d'état les attendent de voir ce que ça
donne et pourrait en gros essayer d'être
en s'immisçant moins possible du côté du
vainqueur et ce qui n'est pas le cas de
la france qui a toujours des prétentions
avoir instauré la démocratie telle
qu'elle l'entend partout dans le monde
notamment l'afrique qui est une des
dernières zones sur lesquelles on les
écoute encore un petit peu donc c'est à
mon avis c'est très habile de la part
des autorités maliennes de jouer la
carte de wagner qui pour l'instant ne
donne pas de va pas entraîner un
bouleversement de rapports de force sur
terrain merci en tout cas tous les deux
pour votre analyse et les sommiers
xavier moreau merci d'avoir été avec
nous